good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-3084
object class
euclid
special containment procedures
instances of scp-3084 encountered in the
field are to be seized documented and
stored within site-28 secure archives
full screenings of scp-3084 are
permitted only to individuals assigned
to activities within plane 3084
for established risk management
protocols personnel cleared to enter
plane 3084 for research purposes are to
spend no more than eight hours within
this space during any seven day period
and no more than 25 hours in any 30-day
period medical and psychological
screenings will be administered to
personnel assigned to this function on a
weekly basis
description
scp-3084 is a silent film titled seven
strangers at a feast the majority of the
film appears to have been made at some
point in the late 1920s however certain
elements suggest that parts of the film
may have been made earlier or later than
this time period
scp-3084 has a tonal run time of 2 hours
and 17 minutes apart from an initial
title play card
scp-3084 does not feature any title
cards to indicate dialogue nor any
indication that a musical score of any
kind was intended no records of the
film's purported director jacob and
quenziza have been verified to exist
in approximately 40 percent of
documented cases persons viewing
scp-3084 in its entirety become capable
of accessing a trans physical space
designated plane 3084 upon completion of
their first viewing of the film within
three to five days after the initial
viewing these subjects will develop an
intuitive ability to enter a trance-like
state at will and appear to vanish from
observation upon achieving this state
during this time subjects are
transported through unknown means to
plane 3084. persons entering plane 3084
in this manner are able to return to
baseline reality at will and reappear in
the same location in space upon
returning
research indicates that at least six
persons have entered plane 3084 since
its creation including two foundation
personnel plane 3084 is believed to have
been created through anomalous means at
the same time as scp-3084
plane 3084 is a trans-physical space
closely resembling locations depicted in
seven strangers at a feast geographical
features structures and ambient weather
conditions all appear to exactly match
locations that appear in the film it is
not believed that scp-3884 was filmed
within plane 3884 rather plane 3084 is
understood to be a place generated
concurrently with the act of filming
scp-3084
scp-3084 was first documented among the
effects of george cecil jones person of
interest 3663 collected posthumously as
part of the larger monitoring efforts of
operation lawbreaker in the 1960s where
its anomalous traits were observed upon
processing the numerous artifacts in the
jones estate jones and other figures
targeted in the course of lawbreaker are
not believed to be the intended
recipients of scp-3084 copies at least
30 copies of scp-3084 are known to have
been distributed anonymously in the
1920s in london paris brussels rome and
several other european cities most have
been recovered from individuals
occupying high profile positions in
business the military or the aristocracy
who are believed to be the intended
recipients of scp-3084
at the time addendum 3084 1 synopsis of
scp-3084
seven strangers at a feast is an
experimental film deviating in style and
subject material from most efforts of
the late silent film era these
differences include the extended running
time lack of an easily discernible story
or plot depictions of graphic violence
utilizing special effects far in advance
of those available at the time and
repeated use of abstract imagery no
actors in the film have yet been
positively identified indicating that
scp-3084 is in amateur production
character names in the description below
have been assigned by research staff as
no credits beyond the initial title card
are present in scp-3084
scenes one to eight
these scenes take place in and around an
isolated country house and include
several establishing shots five
characters are introduced as they arrive
at the country house all depicted
walking along a dirt road leading to the
location the young man the young woman
the aristocrat the general and the boy
all of the characters gather at the
front door of the country house the
aristocrat and the general argue
heatedly apparently about whether to
enter the house or concerning a possible
plan of action once inside the house the
young man young woman and boy are silent
throughout the exchange with the
expressions of worry or fear throughout
most scenes
scenes 9-13
the old woman appears for the first time
aimlessly wandering in the interior of
the country house the scenes are dimly
lit while her face is obscured
throughout the film the old woman can be
interpreted to be muttering to herself
by her hand and head movements and
occasionally yelling in the empty house
the old woman pauses occasionally to
look with apparent apprehension at a
chest next to the unlit hearth in the
middle of the house
scenes
14-27
the argument between the aristocrat and
the general suddenly stops the two men
stand silently at the door to the house
while the general beckons the boy to
join them the boy resists and attempts
to hide behind the young man the young
man appears confused and attempts to
prevent the boy from coming near him the
young woman suddenly flees the scene and
runs into the woods surrounding the
house
scenes 28-30
inside the country house the old woman
shuffles closer to the front door
appearing to dance in an erratic fashion
until reaching the door at which point
she appears to start shaking
uncontrollably while stretching her arms
skyward
scenes
31-43
the young woman runs through the now
darkened woods surrounding the country
house the film quality appears to
deteriorate and change during this
extended sequence the lighting of the
scene grows darker and darker as the
young woman continues to flee her
apparent terror increasing steadily the
woods are barely discernible by scene 38
and the young woman begins to be beset
by shapeless apparitions emerging from
the darkness starting in scene 41. by
scene 43 the woman is almost entirely
out of focus only recognizable by
frantic exaggerated movements
scenes
44-51
the aristocrat kicks down the front door
of the country house finding the old
woman standing in the doorway he roughly
takes hold of the woman and marches her
inside the general draws his pistol and
motions for the boy to go inside the
house the boy refuses until the general
discharges around into the air the boy
reluctantly goes inside the house the
general apparently tells the young man
to stand by a window looking into the
house and then goes inside himself
scenes 52-59
this portion of the film is entirely
focused on the young man who stays in
place watching the action through the
window the entire time multiple camera
angles apparently utilizing several
varieties of film some appearing to be
of higher quality than should be
available for the time are utilized the
young man grows increasingly
uncomfortable and disturbed by what he
is witnessing presumably the events
depicted in scene 60 of the film but
does not move from his spot by the
window
scene 60
the longest individual scene in the film
the old woman is forced down onto a long
table in front of the hearth by the
aristocrat and the general her clothing
apart from the hood which continues to
obscure her face is torn away and the
two men methodically fix the old woman
into place by driving long nails through
her wrists and ankles into the table the
boy is then made to sit and observe by
the general the aristocrat and the
general use long thin knives to flay the
old woman's legs placing the skin on top
of the chest next to the hearth the skin
appears to begin smoldering the
aristocrat then opens a long incision in
the old woman's torso together the
aristocrat in the general removes
several ribs carefully cutting away
tissue until the cleansed bones are
placed on top of the chest as well the
bones float in place over the pile of
skin which is now apparently on fire the
general dips a vessel into the old
woman's now open abdominal cavity and
pours several cupfuls of blood on top of
the chest causing the flames to grow
substantially the boy watching him
passively to this point gets up from his
seat at the request of the aristocrat
the boy reaches into the incision of the
old woman's torso and retrieves what
appears to be a set of eyes the eyes
rise out of the boy's palm and travel
first over the aristocrat then the
general before descending into the pyre
atop the chest the fire stops and the
chest opens
the guest a charred skeletal figure
rises from inside the chest the boy the
aristocrat and the general arrange six
chairs around the table upon which the
old woman is still fastened and
apparently still alive the aristocrat
beckons to the window from which the
young man is still watching motioning
for him to come inside the guest assumes
a position at the head of the table
scene 61-63
the young woman continues to run
frantically in darkness finally coming
up on an isolated doorway deep into the
woods as the shapeless apparitions
continue to pursue the young woman opens
the door and hurries inside closing it
behind her
scenes 64-68
the young woman appears spontaneously
inside the country house as the chairs
have been arranged around the table and
the old woman she makes no reaction as
the aristocrat the general and the young
man draped the scraps of the old woman's
clothes onto her and the boy seats her
at the foot of the table opposite the
guest the rest of the characters take
their seats around the table the guest
begins clawing at the flesh of the old
woman with his hands taking portions
from her limbs the flesh appears to cook
while in the guests hands the guest
hands portions of flesh to each
character and turn around the table each
of whom devours the offering quickly
this is repeated several times
scenes 69 69-74
scene 69 suddenly cuts to a clean
skeleton affixed to the table the
characters still seated around the table
save the guest who is absent the
aristocrat the general and the young man
stand up and leave the house the boy
removes the hood still present on the
skull of the old woman and drapes it
over the unresponsive young woman still
seated at the opposite end of the table
season 74 consists of a continuous shot
of the now obscured face of the young
woman lasting 2 minutes and 19 seconds
before the film abruptly ends
addendum 3084 2 research notes volume 1.
initial documentation of scp-3884 and
subsequent exploration of plane 3084 was
undertaken in 1963 by researcher philip
dumont the following are relevant field
notes containing observations and data
collected by dr dumont during his
assignment to scp-3084
prevailing features of plane 3084 12th
of march 1963.
area consists of observable terrain and
traversable terrain observable terrain
is the same as depicted in the film
which must have been shot on location
traversible terrain is the area around
the house the house itself and a small
corridor leading into the surrounding
forest attempts to cross into
non-traversible terrain are met with a
simple inability to proceed further no
feeling of a barrier no visible
indicators you just can't go there
original location is confirmed to be
rusi national park in the kingdom of
burundi this place is a simulacrum
ongoing political instability is
stalling inquiries but unusual that a
largely white production team making a
film here would not be remarked in any
records at the time no records of jacob
and quenziza came up in our background
search and local authorities seemed
quite insistent that they know of no
such person
no persons or in fact any detectable
living organisms present field
microscopic examination of soil and
water samples turn up same
time does not pass in the surrounding
area the sun stays low in the sky and
the local time is always 18 30 hours
give or take a few minutes time passes
normally for myself and my pocket watch
house interior assessment 5th of may
1963.
the country house at the center of plane
3084 does not decay but instead
maintains a certain shabby quality as
originally depicted in the film no
amount of force seems to be sufficient
to open the chest by the hearth tools
are being requisitioned for the next
visit unsurprisingly one cannot light a
fire in the hearth
the testimony of duke mckellen who was
known to have visited this place
sometime in the 30s indicates that when
the humanoids corresponding to the
characters of the film dwelt here they
would mostly congregate in the house
when they weren't reenacting scenes two
other individuals suspected to have been
visitors indirectly confirmed this
observation in documents lifted from
their private records but only mckellen
described the routine of the characters
in any detail it is unfortunate that he
only visited once whether this
experience is at all tied to his
supposed nervous disposition in later
years is impossible to say
before these humanoids i hesitate to
call them fully human until we can find
one and examine it left this plane four
parts unknown they were known to spend
hours at a stretch all assembled in the
house standing almost perfectly still
only their eyes moving to follow
visitors unsurprising perhaps that
mckellen did not return for a second
trip
as of this time however no persons are
to be found here
excavation results 17th of august 1963.
the work has been going slowly normally
we would have seven or eight men digging
this place up with suitable equipment
due to our mostly reasonable protocols
for visiting places like these it's just
been me and my shovel following some
study of scenes 65 and 66 and my
observations here i've succeeded in
prying up the floorboards underneath the
dinner table and excavating about a
meter of material i'll be able to test
what i've done once site staff have
finished designing the equipment for
this environment
recovered the following
approximately 35 cubic centimeters of
fabric likely linen various implements
of cutlery likely steel
layers of charred wood and ash
suggesting rebuilding of present
structure on site of previously
destroyed one
10 cups of similar design to those
depicted in scene 60 of the film
and scattered skeletal remains almost
certainly human initial examination
suggests at least five different
individuals including two skulls
unlabeled 29th of july 1963.
all of the bones apparently belong to
the same person not the first time we've
encountered this situation but never a
welcome development
forest examination 7 12 of september
1963
i've been feeling along the boundaries
of the forest corridor for quite some
time on this examination i have found a
narrow pathway part way into the
corridor that appears to correspond to
scenes 31 to 43. this is a unique
portion of the film in that it could
have been filmed anywhere and does not
necessarily represent a fixed location
in this plane this could theoretically
account for the whereabouts of the
film's characters who have not been
present in this plane since at the very
least
1954 likely that i will be undertaking
further explorations of this new side
corridor in 50 meter increments during
my next scheduled visits
unlabeled 23rd of september 1963.
i haven't taken a sound recorder since
the first few visits i must remember to
bring one next time
unlabeled 28th of september 1963.
it gets darker here something about this
specific place in the forest is most
certainly different the tapes don't seem
to play anything back but i'm
increasingly certain that there is some
form of life in the woods
dr dumont's field notes conclude at the
28th of september 1963 entry dr dumont
did not return as scheduled from his
28th of september 1963 visit to plane
3084 and was officially listed missing
in action until the 28th of september
1968 when he was recovered in a
significantly agitated state from a
police station in lions france after
attempting to clandestinely contact
foundation assets in the area dr dumont
wasn't able to recall his whereabouts
for the previous five-year period in
debriefings and was granted a medical
retirement several months later
addendum 3084-3 update and analysis
at the request of assistant researcher
rania kasar
scp-3084 was reauthorized for
examination on the 12th of october 2016
as part of a training and development
assignment assistant researcher kasar
was granted security clearance for plane
3084 as part of a comprehensive data
review and entry revision procedure and
has filed the following addendum
review focus 1 known visitors to plane
3084.
dorian giroux 5th duke of mckellen
mckellen is known from his personal
testimony to an undercover foundation
operative in the 1960s to have received
a copy of scp-3084
and viewed it the then duke of mckellen
was at one time a prominent member of
the belgian royal family however he grew
estranged from them in the 1930s this is
concurrent with the time period of his
first and only visit to plane 3084 which
he described as a disturbing and
unpleasant experience
at the time of his visit plane 3084 was
populated by simulacra of the characters
depicted in seven strangers at a feast
these characters would reenact the
events of the film on a fixed cycle of
time completing a performance and then
retiring to the country house for a
period of several hours before repeating
mckellen apparently witnessed two full
performances from a fixed perspective
inside the country house noting that the
characters would interact with him if
engaged during portions of the film's
narrative that were set outside of the
house
in the account of mckellen these
characters would not speak but would
engage non-verbally he notes being
warmly greeted by the aristocrat in the
general and regarded with fear by the
young man on several occasions the
aristocrat appeared to instruct the boy
to stay in mckellen's vicinity which
mckellen discouraged when pressed
mckellen claimed to not remember any
interactions with the guest hermann von
dietrich
von dietrich was primarily known as a
substantial owner of ruracol ag a large
german mining company and personally
oversaw operations at the delacroix gold
complex in what is now the central
african republic von dietrich was also a
major investor in film studio babelsberg
a significant organization in early
german cinema
in a letter to eric palmer an
influential german film producer von
dietrich recounts what he describes as a
dream following his viewing of a film
delivered to his offices in frankfurt
the contents of this dream are believed
to be an account of a visit to plane
3084.
von dietrich describes a different set
of interactions than mckellen von
dietrich recounts a landscape exactly as
that of the peculiar film screened in my
private theater the night prior where
all of the characters of seven strangers
at a feast are arrayed inside the house
similar to scene 67 of the film the
guest is said to have addressed him
directly speaking in a loud deep voice
repeatedly stating peter kill and eat
while directing von dietrich to partake
of the titular feast
despite expressing a desire to leave
this scene in his recounting of the
event von dietrich describes being
handed a gilded plate and sitting down
at the table and then eating several
handfuls of flesh handed to him by the
guest
his description of the event follows
each morsel that i ate was delectable as
though i had been famished and finally
set to a meal after a long day's ride
out of the jungle and yet my gut
recoiled at the foul knowledge of what i
was eating i could feel each individual
bite swirling in my stomach wishing to
heave up the contents that and there on
the table even as i licked the grease
from my lips and held out my plate for
more
von dietrich describes similar scenes to
this one as a recurring dream in
subsequent correspondence records of
hermann von dietrich become much more
sparse following his divestment from
ruracol ag in 1932 and he is believed to
have perished in the opening years of
world war ii
archibald reign and emilia homewood
archibald reign a director of the
london-based shaw brothers export bank
is confirmed via postal receipts of the
time to have received a copy of seven
strangers at a feast unlike other known
recipients reign is believed to have
been fascinated and intrigued by the
film watching it repeatedly and
analyzing its contents in his private
journal in his repeated visits to plane
3084 he describes experiences similar to
those encountered by duke mckellen
in 1947
reigns showed the film to amelia
holmwood a fringe figure in the london
spiritualism community earlier in the
century known primarily for her work in
automatic photography homewood began
accompanying rain on visits to plane
3084 and the pair studied the film and
its associated phenomenon intensely
eventually both persons came to the
conclusion that the film's primary theme
was liberation and that plane 3084
represented a realm analogous to
christian concepts of purgatory
range journal entries become
increasingly obtruse after reaching this
conclusion crouched heavily in
terminology and concepts apparently
borrowed from libra alveolus and other
works associated with the thalema
movement references to reversing the
course appear frequently and accounts of
subsequent visits to plane 3084 suggests
that several characters of seven
strangers at a feast are now absent from
the plane both rain and homewood appear
to have disappeared some time after
february of 1950 with rain being
declared legally dead in 1958 after a
lengthy inquest into the disposition of
his estate
review focus 2 jacob unkrenzisa
at the conclusion of this review no
official records of jacob unquenziza
have been confirmed to exist based on
thematic and stylistic examinations of
several other works of anomalous art
from the period however encronzisa is
believed to have been associated with
other documented scps the clouds burned
down anomalous visual phenomena in 1923
6.6 dash unexplained telegraph signal
1924 and the final parliament
manufactured mass delusional episode
madrid 1930.
references to black jacob appear in
correspondence between groups known to
be associated with anomalous art in
western europe between 1919 and 1928.
these are suspected to refer to jacob
unquenziza
cultural analysis of these artworks
suggests that jacob ungrenziza was born
and spent significant amounts of time in
the kingdom of burundi at some point in
his life incrensiza likely received a
european style university education the
extent to which his work appears to have
been recognized in the larger artistic
community consists primarily of negative
reactions to several of his pieces in
the dataist movement
historical analysis of artistic
subcultures and associated works have
identified possible appearances by
enkrenziza in 1942 1957
1979 1988 289 and 2014. despite the
apparent anachronism of these
occurrences jacob unquenziza cannot be
declared inactive at this time
review focus 3 recent photographic
records british field exercises kenya
1960 leftmost figure 94 biometric match
for entity 3084 2 the general only known
photo
recovered during automated search
algorithm 10th of october 2017
provisionally quarantined remote site
3084 a 2017 house closely matching that
depicted in
scp-3084 spontaneously appears in annuis
province france forensic examination
pending
photo courtesy of site-28 research staff
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zolfax99
ianj alsup
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
talk of villagers
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy african submarine vore
amir saban
seventy
kristoff kozak zlazak
hms lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua
pure osmium
sciodio demnatus
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
drew peacock
eric corbage
longinus
james saba
and nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vogen
thank you
you